Pete Davidson Grew From an exceptionally
challenging childhood to an adult life
marred by public scrutiny from periods
and Rehab to struggles with physical and
mental disorders these are the tragic
details of Davidson's life Pete
Davidson's early life was marred by
trauma in a way that few other people
ever experience when he was only 7 years
old his father was killed during the
September 11th attacks in New York Scott
Matthew Davidson was a firefighter in
the city and was part of the response
team that attended the World Trade
Center according to eyewitness accounts
Scott was last seen running up the
stairs of the Marriott World Trade
Center Hotel moments before the Twin
Towers collapsed completely destroying
the building and killing almost everyone
who was inside Scott who graduated from
the fire academy in 1994 before joining
ladder company 118 in Brooklyn Heights
had always dreamed of being a
firefighter he was 33 years old at the
time of his death Pete remembers him
with a tattoo on his left arm of his
father's badge number alongside a
replica of the helmet he wore while on
duty Scott's influence May well have
been a significant factor in Pete
becoming a comedian as an adult as an
old school mate of the Fallen fighter
recalled to the New York Post Scott was
always clowning around telling jokes
making people laugh despite the tragic
nature of his father's death Davidson
has dealt with the loss with strength
even making jokes about his father's
passing when
appropriate considering the traumatic
loss of his father it's not surprising
that Davidson didn't have the perfect
childhood the death of his father in
such a shocking way was overwhelming for
the young boy and his mother Amy
Davidson told the New York Times that
the future comedian's upbringing was
very sad according to the outlet
Davidson attended three different high
schools due to conflicts with other
students and his own bad behavior he
even pulled out his own hair as a result
of his emotional turmoil he eventually
came to realize that the problem wasn't
other kids it was him speaking on
peacock's talk show heart tohe heart
Davidson explained that it wasn't just
his father's death that negatively
affected his childhood the fact that his
mother was a single parent and he had a
very young sister also had an effect on
him despite his family being loving and
supportive single mom like new sister
just like did not handle it great it may
seem odd but Pete Davidson credits kid
Cy with saving his life as a child his
mental health issues led to the
youngster having suicidal thoughts and
the comedian has since admitted that he
believes that he may well have ended his
own life if it wasn't for the rapper and
singer in particular Davidson says that
the 2009 album man on the moon the end
of day saved his life he confirmed this
in an interview with Power 105.1 the
Breakfast Club saying I would have
killed myself absolutely 100% I truly
believe if man on the moon didn't come
out I wouldn't be here the comedian said
the emotional nature of kid C's music
struck a chord with him and many other
young people in recent years kid Cy has
spoken out about his own mental health
problems with the musici ition entering
rehab for depression in 2016 as an adult
Davidson has even gotten to work with
his Idol and he continues to appreciate
that kid Cy was willing to speak so
openly about his personal
experiences Davidson was first diagnosed
with crohn's disease when he was still a
teenager Crohn's disease is a condition
where parts of the digestive system
become inflamed causing a variety of
painful symptoms such as diarrhea
stomach cramps and fatigue once
diagnosed Crohn's disease is not curable
patients live with it for the rest of
their lives however available treatments
can help manage symptoms and allow those
living with the disease to live
relatively normal lives treatments
include medicines to help alleviate
symptoms and also surgery to remove
small parts of the digestive system that
become particularly inflamed during
flareups the unpredictable nature of the
condition means that it can be
challenging to live with as it is
impossible to know exactly when the
symptoms will occur Davidson has been
open about how the condition affects him
telling High Times that the disease
would cause him so much pain he couldn't
eat however he found that smoking
cannabis proved a reliable solution to
this issue then I smoke I'd be able to
eat and be able to do my shows and I
won't be able to do SNL if I didn't
smoke weed Davidson has also spoken
openly about having borderline
personality disorder this is a condition
that affects the person's thoughts and
emotions as well as their ability to
communicate with other people those
living with the condition will often act
in a rash manner without considering the
consequences and also have trouble
controlling their emotions exactly what
causes borderline personality disorder
is unclear although it has been linked
with traumatic events Davidson first
revealed the diagnosis during the film
King of Staten Island and he has often
talked about how he struggles with
regular bouts of depression he later
said on the WTF with Mark Maron podcast
that he would have quote mental
breakdowns where he would spiral into a
rage and not remember to spread
awareness about mental health the
comedian spoke up during a feature on
SNL's Weekend Update segment urging
viewers who may be suffering with
depression or similar conditions to talk
to doctors and seek
help first of all if you think you're
depressed you know see a doctor and talk
to them about medication and also be
healthy the former SNL star has
regularly checked into Rehabilitation
Facilities to help address his mental
health most recently he entered a rehab
center in Pennsylvania in 2023 for
inpatient therapy as a result of his
borderline personality disorder and
post-traumatic stress syndrome as a
source close to Davidson confirmed to
people Pete will often check himself
into rehab to work on these issues as
someone who has not been afraid to share
sensitive details of his personal life
it is not particularly surprising that
Pete Davidson has been open about his
addictions as a way of self-medicating
Davidson frequently smokes canabus and
spent two stints in rehab facilities
trying to deal with his use of the drug
after blaming it for intense mood swings
over the course of his career Davidson
has spent time in and out of rehab even
spending a period completely free of
drugs and alcohol as he wrote in a 2017
Instagram post I quit drugs and am happy
and sober for the first time in 8 years
it wasn't easy but I got a great girl
great friends and I consider myself a
lucky man however his sobriety didn't
last long and a year later he was
smoking and drinking again cannabis is
not the only drug that has landed him in
rehab either according to people during
a comedy show with John meany and John
Stewart in September 20123 he revealed
that he had been taking ketamine every
day for 4 years before going to a
rehabilitation facility he even joked to
the audience I got that post-rehab glow
seventh times the charm like many other
edgy comedians Davidson is no stranger
to controversy and has often faced
criticism for many of his jokes during
an SNL sketch in 2019 he compared the
Catholic Church to musician AR Kelly
after the latter had been convicted for
crimes relating to child sex abuse the
year prior the Roman Catholic dicese of
Brooklyn had agreed to pay millions to
settle a lawsuit alleging sexual
misconduct the same dicese demanded an
apology from the show and Davidson in
response to the joke his Netflix special
Pete Davidson presents alive from New
York also Drew condemnation from many
people within the gay community for what
were perceived to be homophobic jokes
more recently the Netflix special Pete
Davidson presents the best friends also
caused controversy for jokes referencing
AIDS and Jeffrey Epstein the comedian
also famously apologized to Republican
politician Dan khaw for mocking the eye
patch he wears you may be Sur surprised
to hear he's a Congressional candidate
from Texas and not a Hitman in a porno
movie sadly crenell wears the imatch as
a result of an injury he received while
on active duty in Afghanistan even so
Davidson later retracted his apology to
the
politician in 2018 Davidson caused
concern when he posted a cryptic message
on Instagram in the wake of his public
split with his ex fiance Ariana Grande
Davidson wrote I'm trying to understand
how when something happens to a guy the
whole entire world just trashes him
without any facts or frame of reference
he also complained that he had been
bullied for 9 months seemingly in
reference to his relationship with the
musician several days later police
performed a welfare check after Davidson
again posted on Instagram this time with
a message suggesting he was having
suicidal thoughts he later deleted his
social media accounts altogether further
distressing fans however he did continue
to appear on Saturday Night Live though
neither he nor NBC have issued a
statement regarding the posts he made
with Kim Kardashian being one of the
most well-known people on the planet the
fact that she was dating Pete Davidson
made headlines around the world this
news was further heightened due to her
recent split with her ex-husband Kanye
West who was seemingly unhappy with the
pair seeing each other in February 2022
West launched a TI raade against
Davidson and even encouraged fans to
verbally harass him in public the
musician was later banned from Instagram
for 24 hours after making threatening
remarks to both Davidson and fellow
comedian Trevor Noah West continued to
post about Davidson and his relationship
with Kim Kardashian months later even
after the pair eventually split the
negative attention and threats from West
took a toll on Davidson in August 2022
it was revealed that the comedian was in
trauma therapy as a result of his
interactions with West as a source told
people the attention and negativity
coming from Kanye and his Antics is a
trigger for Pete and he's had to seek
out help although they were no longer
together Kardashian was supportive of
Davidson seeking therapy and criticized
the behavior of her
ex-husband Pete Davidson was one of the
youngest ever cast members to join SNL
first appearing on the show when he was
just 20 years old however that doesn't
mean that the experience has always been
enjoyable while he said he is thankful
for the opportunities it has given him
Davidson has also spoken out about how
he feels he has been poorly treated at
times by his fellow writers and
comedians speaking to Charlemagne the
God Davidson revealed that he doesn't
feel like the show has his back despite
having a strong relationship with
executive producer Lauren Michaels
Davidson believed that when he wasn't
around his colleagues and castmates
would talk poorly of him behind his back
which upset and Confused the rising star
on John bernthal's real ones podcast
Davidson went into more detail about how
jokes about his personal life made
working on the show more difficult he
explained that there were moments on the
show where a joke would be made at his
expense and then he'd need to walk on
stage to the derisive laughter of the
audience he stated that over time that
began to take a toll on his own
self-image you know because it seems
like all really talented people are sick
don't worry Kum me and you are good
okay anyone who is familiar with Pete
Davidson will know that he has an
extensive number of tattoos across his
entire body these range from references
to previous girlfriends to designs by
his friends like Machine Gun Kelly to
Pieces he purposefully got while filming
a role the comedian even has a matching
tattoo with Miley Cyrus as the two
appeared in an SNL sketch together where
they played babies Davidson has in
recent years begun to have many of these
tattoos removed he explained on Late
Night with Seth Meers that this was a
decision he made because of his career
in Hollywood it takes so long to cover
up the tattoos when filming that it made
more sense for the comedian to get rid
of them completely what many people may
not realize though is that one of the
reasons that Davidson started getting
tattoos in the first place was to cover
up scars from self harm speaking with
Charlemagne the God Davidson noted that
some of the tattoos on his chest
specifically are there to hide scars
from cutting himself there he also
revealed that at times he saw self harm
as his only option for a release while
stressed saying whenever you're so Manic
and upset sometimes that's the only
thing that will work for me thankfully
davidon stins and Rehab have exposed him
to healthier coping mechanisms in
situations where he feels emotionally
overwhelmed if you or anyone you know
needs help with addiction issues help is
available visit the Substance Abuse and
Mental Health Services Administration
website or contact samsa's National
helpline at 1800 662 help
oh